hi thanks very much can everybody hear
me yeah it's okay good so I'm Ben and
I'm from London despite my accent and
I'm going to talk to you a little bit
about trying to work out if sentiment
has any tie to the quality of writing is
the more generic way to state that
question and so what we're going to do
is use this idea of angry people and on
the one hand in and grammar or stylistic
notions on the other as a way to sort of
poke at what we can do with
understanding language and Python and
also doing some statistical dependency
analysis in Python although I should
warn you there's probably going to be
only slightly more Python in actual
slides than it the Julia talk next door
so we'll probably beat that one but only
because they're not even talking about
Python okay so with that in mind let's
talk a little bit about what the point
of this is and where it comes from so um
I don't know how many people in the room
you say Twitter like on a semi-regular
basis daily weekly whatever okay so have
you ever noticed on something like
Twitter or really any sort of short form
social media that that people who are
loud and loud is a sort of metaphorical
usage here caps lock is screaming ! et
cetera they they don't necessarily put
their words together very well but like
that well sure yeah you know oh and and
and i will say that that that my country
the United States we we do our part here
right so you know and people yell about
things they argue but but do they really
get angrier and also get less well
considered because because I have this
this sort of idea I everyone sees these
things of all caps and poor grammar and
using the wrong form of two and
splitting their infinitives and whatever
other particular grammar rules using
literally incorrectly you know all these
other providers sorts of things but the
problem is that that there's this notion
in psychology a confirmation bias does
anyone know confirmation bias it's my
favorite so so basically you're more
likely to remember a thing if
confirms what you already thought was
going on right happens all over the
place and it's it's one there are many
sort of little psychological things that
are reasons why we in this sort of
community do our best when we sort of go
and poke at the data and as neutral away
as possible and so so can we do that
with this question and I think we can
and it can maybe it can look like this
so first we have to find a pile of
comments right we'll get back to where
we can do that later and then somehow we
need to measure the style in a
quantitative way and also measure the
sentiment in some way that gives us some
numbers and then I don't know we're
going to do something else and then and
then somehow will profit and that'll be
great so so what do I mean so so we need
to do statistical dependence and to do
statistical dependence we are simply
going to work out if that first side
that measured style has anything
whatsoever to do with that second side
the sentiment and then I don't know what
profit means I guess it means I'll get
more twitter followers out of this
that's what this all is circular right
so we talked about social media than we
do better on social media that we talk
about social media let me do it it's all
it's great okay so let's find a pile of
comments so the pile of comments is from
reddit so I don't know if anyone's
familiar last year there was a really
good community driven effort to package
up everything that's ever been uttered
on reddit wrap it in some jason and seed
out some torrents of it it's a really
great resource for doing lots of the
kind of work we're going to talk about
for the next half hour or so but there's
a lot of the tremendous amount of other
possibilities with this data set I
highly encourage you to go pick it up
have a play with it it's also a really
good way to sort of flex your muscles
with highly paralyzed work because as
I'll get to in a minute you can't simply
run this volume of data on a laptop so
if you really want to get through all of
the data you need to use some more sort
of big data approaches so here's here's
the magnet link I'm sharing I'm sharing
a some torrents but they're legal so
that that data said in fact is 1.7
trillion reddit comments uh that's so I
think it was last up
a couple of months ago though there is a
sort of idea that will steadily grow
with monthly updates so you do have to
be careful if you sort of use it to be
clear about which sort of time version
you use if you want to be comparing data
results with other people also handling
there's a separate torrent that has the
exact same formatted data but strictly
for the month of January from last year
and just that month it's 59 million
reddit comments this is what we're going
to be sort of working with in this
because most of these methods I've
optimized for sort of clarity and
understanding and exploration which
means that they aren't the fastest
things in the world and so getting
through 1.7 trillion comments can take
weeks so rather than doing that we're
just going to use the sort of subset and
actually what I've done is sampled about
1% of that data so we can just sort of
burn through things and do some
visualization and whatever and it
doesn't take too long and in particular
I'm running that through this filter
here's the first bit Python so so we're
using tokenized from the natural
language toolkit which is not its last
appearance in this slide deck and this
is a simple but not necessarily fast way
to break up words or excuse me break up
large chunks of text into nominally
words but like sort of small pieces of
meaning and then we can count them and
what we're doing is skipping all the
comments that are sufficiently short
that we don't trust the results from
either the style and grammar or from the
sentiment so anything that's less than
five words we're assuming is not enough
to have reliable analysis on both sides
were throwing lab and so that gets us to
319,000 comments from january of last
year which is quite a bit smaller than
our original set but is still a very
large amount of data and will get us
some nice p values at the end to sort of
tease out okay so how do we do this step
2 measuring style and sentiment so the
first thing is grammar which is in the
title so you might think that's what
we're going to do so let's let's look at
grammar so if you think grammar and
computers and computer science probably
well maybe you think context-free
grammar and actually the roux
how many of you have ever done any sort
of context-free grammar parsing the sort
of thing linguistic analysis anybody
hands okay so a few okay so the idea
with a context-free grammar and is that
you can take a series of texts and you
can analyze it without having to have a
complete mapping of the words and the
relationship of the word based on their
type you can also use context-free
grammars to do analysis of programming
languages not just sort of spoken ones
but so it's great for analyzing
ambiguous situations and complexity and
things like this and there's a really
good example that I have shamelessly
stolen from the natural language toolkit
a book on these topics here's one
morning i shot an elephant my pajamas oh
we got in my pajamas I don't know okay
so that's that's this text I'm going to
thoroughly ruin this joke I apologize
for any marks fans so Oh one morning i
shot an elephant in my pajamas how he
got in my pajamas I don't know so the
critical thing that's fun here is this
part right here and and the joke if it
isn't clear is that it's not exactly
obvious who is in pajamas right so what
we can do is analyze this using a
context-free grammar if we don't care
about the sort of infinite possibilities
of English but just this particular
bounds we can use it with quite a simple
grammar so we've defined the grammar
this way so to quickly run through
things s is a sentence that's our sort
of largest nominal unit of information
and sentences every sentence in this
grammar has a noun phrase and a verb
phrase that's NP and then VP we can then
define what each of these things sort of
mean recursively so as we do sort of
down here and I apologize for not
spending too much time on this but we're
going to have to sort of push through
for time but so we have these various
things where you have one unit of
information that represents a particular
grammar rule and those rules build on
top of each other and then at the bottom
we define the different types so a
determinate isn't an or
my a noun is elephant or pajamas and I
misspelled pajamas and slide sorry and
such so we can then use that and we can
build a parse of our confused sentence
again this is not too hard with a little
bit of NLT k magic and this is this is a
simple parser parsing context-free
grammars i should say is sort of a topic
deserving its own series of talks there
are many ways to do it they have
different pros and cons this particular
message chart parser is useful because
when it's done you get these which are
charts of the relationships based on the
grammar rules but I I don't I mean maybe
if there's some people who sort of grew
up on list they're good at these levels
of parenthesis I sort of think this is
easier to get through if we sort of draw
a tree and this is something that if you
start looking at grammars and grammar
analysis you'll see quite a lot of this
sort of thing so the basic idea here is
that we have two different ways of
understanding this sentence one of which
understands that the elephant is in fact
in the pajamas and the other one that
the man who is doing the shooting is in
the pajamas and specifically in fact
let's see so the one over on the left
from your view is doing both shot an
elephant and in my pajamas are referring
to the eye so here Groucho Marx is
wearing pajamas and shooting an elephant
on the other hand on the right we have
that I that's Groucho Marx has shot an
elephant the elephant is wearing pajamas
and and the ambiguity of course is where
the joke comes from and again i
apologize for thoroughly ruining Groucho
Marx jokes so that's all from this
grammar but that grammar obviously
that's not all the rules of English
right and I hope that everyone can sort
of see that in the room English in fact
has many many many more complicated
rules and relationships between nouns
and verbs and adjectives and other ways
to form sentences and such and in fact
if we extend that forever and always and
thousands of times
can at least in theory define English
except that really it's it's a static
simplification even at best right
because language is full of nuance you
saw it in the example there were two
different ways to tree that out and also
language is always sort of moving so if
we define a contacted grammar and then
we sort of take a breath that it
probably won't fully describe the ways
that people speak to each other and
write English sentences so there's this
idea of a pcfg which is a probabilistic
context-free grammar and that helps a
little bit because then we can sort of
say all right so in this particular case
we have a 30-percent likelihood that
this is the correct rule and a
70-percent like that's the correct rule
this sort of thing so you can assign
effectively weights to ambiguities and
that's better but but the the thing as
this this lovely quote sort of
summarizes is that there's not really a
holistic agreement on what is
grammatically correct right and as as a
sort of American who is now living in
the UK I see this on a regular basis
there's also a no real notion of a sort
of uniformity across english as a second
language speakers so you have you have a
sort of core idea of what well spoken
english looks like but there are so many
edges and so much fuzz that actually may
be thinking about grammar is not quite
what i mean maybe we want something a
little different maybe we want to sort
of test for style so so the nice thing
about style is we can arbitrarily say
these are the things that we like these
are the things that are concise that are
easy to read that are clear that our
professional whatever so so does anyone
familiar with linters does anyone link
their code pile in pylons the common 14
for this language okay so so pilant
doesn't say whether or not your code is
correct it doesn't say we're not your
code will run it says whether your code
conforms to the norms of our come you
which handily and python are quite well
defined in public but you see this for
all sorts of programming languages and
indeed there are projects to do this
with English prose lint is a a
reasonably young project that I am not
directly affiliated with this is not an
advertisement that I was paid for but
it's a lovely tool uh and and in fact
you can you can sort of test it although
not here all at once or the Wi-Fi may
come down but this is a live nice little
piece of JavaScript so you can just type
in a box and it hovers over the rules
when you violate things whatever it's
quite lovely the core of it is this a
piece of sort of a config file excuse me
that defines the rules that we care
about so so Rosalind has a specific
definition of various stylistic
considerations from all sorts canonical
places lots of writers various style
guidelines from places like the AP and
other canonical sources for things and
then you can go through and you can say
which things you care about so for
instance you have consistency spacing
and consistency spelling so consistency
spacing does not mine if you use one
space after punctuation or two spaces
after punctuation which is a great way
to start a fight on a english-language
comment board but they want to make sure
that whichever one you use you use the
same throughout your language right
similarly it doesn't take a position on
whether or not British English or
American English is the correct way to
spell things only that you're
consistently applying them throughout so
if you use a you when you spell color
that's fine as long as you do the same
the next time so this is quite useful
and so we can look at for instance a
definition here so this is this is
looking at checking for repeated
exclamations and all its really doing is
running a reg ex to see if you've used
lots and lots of exclamation part points
over and over again instead of just one
or occasionally two and then it prints
out an informative message associated
with the rule which here is a stop
yelling keep your excavation points
under can
troll okay so we can run this parcel
inter and we can do it over our entire
data set of comments and if we do that
we get some results everyone likes
results so uh so this is this is a count
of a lit of issues brought up by the
linter / comment across our whole data
set and then the second row is the same
counts but normalized against the length
of the comment expressed in tokens so
it's the count of tokens as the divisor
the idea here is that it's reasonable to
assume that for sort of the same quality
comment you would expect a longer
comment to have more issues in absolute
terms so one thing to note actually is
that surprisingly in reddit you don't
have a lot of stylistic trouble so so
this distribution is actually quite flat
for most of its time and will cycle back
to this a little later as well when we
start comparing it to sentiment but you
know the mean is not very high with a
reasonably type standard deviation so it
takes all the way to the 75th percentile
for raw counts to get 21 / comment now I
mean the comments are not massively long
we're talking about you know a dozen
tokens maybe 15 this kind of thing so
when you when you divide them out that
does bear out but you still of course
aren't affecting the distribution wait
fine okay so let's let's talk about
centamin alisis so how many of you have
done any sentiment alisis previously we
have scattering at the same okay so so
sentiment house is what we're trying to
were trying to go from from a block of
text to an understanding of conveyed
meaning positive neutral negative is the
sort of typical grouping and in fact the
grouping that will be using here there's
also another idea of sort of intensity
right so so do you are you just are you
gently expressing your point or are you
really trying to beat at home
and so there are not there are many
approaches for doing centamin alisis
many of them are sort of considered as
supervised learning classification
problems where you take some features
from your writing and then you try and
stick it into a class of positive or a
class of negative or class of neutral
some types of grady ations between them
these sorts of things the problem with
most of these things is that they tend
to fall over with shorter texts and even
with our sort of threshold infiltration
we don't have the luxury of working with
paragraphs and paragraphs of text per
item and this is thankfully been quite a
common case for this kind of work for a
while and some very nice people have
sorted out a pretty good system for
dealing with short especially kind of
social media methodologies called vader
which stands for the valence aware
dictionary of sentiment reasoning i
should say so a bunch of the slides have
URLs down here and i'll put all of them
up so you can see all of my sources for
this this is a very readable paper in
this case from the designers of this
system but Vader is entirely rule-based
which is useful because it's reasonably
quick and you don't have to train a set
it does have sort of built-in biases and
assumptions but those biases and
assumptions are roughly the ones we want
because we're dealing with reddit
comments so Vader was designed and
tested around Twitter but it's
reasonable to assume and this is the
assumption will make that the behavior
on Twitter is roughly analogous to the
behavior that we see on reddit even if
reddit doesn't quite have the strict
character limits that you see on Twitter
so to give you just an example of what
Vader looks like and does this is from
the their paper so we have some sort of
tests and explanations of what's going
on so here we see a eight different
conditions that are broken apart so what
it's doing is it's looking and breaking
up the text based on things that it sees
going on so you have a basic piece of
text that sort of as flat says yay
another good phone interview and then
there's the addition of punctuation an
exclamation point in the second p
and then there's a punctuation and also
a degree modifier so the that third one
uses the word extremely and that use
extremely sort of flags it up as pushing
the intensity and etc all the way down
getting more y le by way of caps lock
perhaps expressing themselves via more
exclamation points and and you know they
go through in the paper and there's
there's some very good research that
sort of backs this particular set of
rules to show that it lines up with a
human intuition about the meaning of the
sentences and yeah and it's also open
source and their data set is open source
it's quite easy to use it's been
integrated into the natural language
toolkit and a few other pieces so it's
pretty easy to just sort of run through
and so indeed we can run it on our data
set and when we do so we get we get
these fine results I don't know is that
exactly from the back can you guys see
my tables of numbers yeah yeah okay
great so um the the basic point here
actually is that things are not as
negative as we might have feared and
actually it's quite neutral so and this
sort of bears out if you just sort of
pick a random reddit comment out and
have a read most of them are just sort
of flat most of people are having
sensible and reasonable conversations so
that's nice that makes you feel better
about humanity although it doesn't if
you wonder about that hypothesis we
started out with but we'll get to that
in a second um it's also just quickly
worth pointing out that these are all
normalized so that they vary from 0 to 1
so you have three independent data
fields positivity negativity and
neutrality and then the intensity of
each of those three ideas right which is
a bit different than how some of the
data analysis can get expressed in other
kinds of sentiment analysis approaches
okay so third item statistical
dependence so statistical dependence in
the most sort of generic way you can
think about it is the idea that you can
define some
I set Y as a function of some set X and
in the sort of simplest case that's one
series of numbers defining another
series of numbers through a function and
in a more complex case you can have
multivariate statistical dependence
where you have many many data sets that
are all going to inform the larger one
as it has anyone anyone does statistical
depends in the room anything anything no
okay a little bit regression anyone
anyone or practitioner of regression
okay so regression is a particular way
that you can look at statistical
dependence it's used quite a bit in our
field I think I think it's a bit in fact
of a crutch but we'll do it anyway so so
this is this is just a sort of rigorous
definition here of least squares which
is the sort of easiest way to do
regression and so if we if we run some
linear regression on our variables we
make this lovely little chart some of
you may recommend or may recognize it
from Seaborn so what we have is that's
the normed Lintz on the top row then
positivity neutrality and negativity and
then the same over so you know what I
think really matters most is that top
row so we're what we're comparing their
is that is the normalized links to each
of the three different variances and you
know at least to my eye and we'll we'll
go through this with a little bit more
math in a second but at least of my eye
there's not actually a lot of
correspondence there right like they're
basically just blobs of dots which isn't
what you expect if there was a clean
dependence there you would expect a nice
line and dots that here pretty close to
that line um and yeah so so let's let's
poke at this a little more so let's
let's do some stricter correlation
testing just to sort of confirm what our
eyes are telling us so we can run Pierce
pearson's is a nice way of testing for
linear correlations it doesn't of course
test for more exciting kinds of
correlation if there was a very exotic
polynomial that led to correlations this
would miss it but that data doesn't
really imply that so if we run a
Pearson's test on both the Lintz just a
negativity we get some very very low
values now when you do correlation
testing a value of zero means that the
data is unrelated that there is no
function aside from an exact enumeration
of data that will define from one set to
the other and when you get to one it
means that there's a nice positive
linear relationship a positive sloping
line and when you get a correlation of
negative one it means is a nice negative
relationship that is exact and complete
and then our p-value so so what this
tells us is basically that there's no
there there that our correlation values
are effectively zero for both the lint
and normalized winter and our p-values
are very very small which means these
are actually pretty reliable results so
it turns out the answer is no to sort of
go back to our question and I mean
that's maybe not that exciting but it's
actually it's it's a strong know so we
have a lot of data and it seems to
reinforce that idea that there isn't
really much of a correlation there so
that's something isn't it so what are
our conclusions so the first thing and
this to me actually was the most
surprising when I started sort of
burying into this data is that it seems
like people on reddit are actually
pretty reasonable at least at large so I
I do sort of wonder actually going
through this as someone who is an
occasional redditor as opposed to
someone that sits on lots and lots of
communities all the time if there's this
distortion effect of of what sort of
bubbles out to the broader populace from
reddit that sort of informs our ideas of
what goes on across all of reddit
because actually most of the
conversation is neutral in sentiment and
reasonably well constructed according to
our style analysis and and beyond that
when it's not reasonable and not
reasonable here I mean sort of negative
and sentiment high intensity negative it
doesn't appear that broadly speaking
it's stylist to be any worse now of
course there are fine examples that we
can pick out we can go through and we
can find the egregious ones but but
looking writ large there's not much of a
dependency between the sort of sentiment
and the stylistic problems at least as
we define our stylistic problems in our
lender and and really I I'm not that
excited about generalizing this so so a
sort of task left to the reader or to me
in a while is to take these processes
that we've done and set them up to
paralyze a bit better run them through
some big data tools Hadoop and such and
run it on the whole data set I and you
know then we can actually sort of make
some statements about the whole of
reddit although my suspicions given how
strong these results are is that it will
generalize but we don't know that until
we try and I think there I'm going to
leave it so I will happily take some
questions and thanks very much for your
attention
would you think that results were
different if you will break the data by
the say category of the topic so people
talking about I T or just some random
news um yeah maybe so I think um having
now sort of done global there's
obviously so so all of the comments the
the distributed data set has subreddit
attachment the the defined communities
on reddit for each comment so it's it
would be quite easy to label the data
out with subreddits um you lose
obviously the sort of total comment
counts right so so I think for for most
reddit communities the participation is
quite low so read it being a place on
the internet it follows a pretty strong
power law distribution so you have a few
subreddits that have seventy eighty
percent of the activity across the whole
site which are things like askreddit and
the the meta community policy subreddit
and the IMA and beyond those you get a
very steep drop-off of activity so I
think it's it's worth exploring my
suspicion is that there will be some
variance so there might be some
communities where you would see actual
correlations between stylistic use and
positive or negative sentiment but um I
mean what this result tells us is that
in most communities you wouldn't expect
that so almost certainly there while
there might be exceptions at a community
level in general especially with very
large communities you expect them to
correspond to this because this is a
pretty strong result at least at the
sort of general level yeah um hi so one
thing I notice about reddit is that it
tends to have certain mimetic behavior
and sometimes people construct people
write a comment in the exact same way
for like hundreds of comments which look
exactly the same because they have
because there's a mean yep so do you
think this could
you your results just taken from reddit
when you extrapolate it to the search to
the entire internet it might actually
turn out different so couldn't skew them
yes do I think it's skewed this sample
probably not and the reason why is
because those sorts of behaviors at
least in that particular example and
there might be other behaviors that
clump a little differently but they tend
to be very time-based so reddit reddit
maybe not as much of a sort of moving
target through time as the the sort of
particular nether regions of 4chan but
it does tend to fluctuate quite quickly
on these sorts of behaviors and so the
sample I took was spread across January
so it was a random random pull of those
comments and my suspicion is that that's
probably enough to blur those sorts of
effects and also just generally a size
right so so because as I mentioned a
second ago the actually surprisingly
large portion of reddit is from the sort
of general comment communities things
like askreddit where you actually don't
see as many of those kinds of behaviors
right I mean there are so one of the
other very large communities is the sort
of thing that read it's famous for this
this thing called advice animals and and
certainly in in that subreddit which is
just full of basically pictures of
animals and their construction into
image memes you do see things like that
but some of them are structural right so
they're not necessarily parroting each
other word for word they're just using
the same sort of structural form in an
almost way that you could almost think
of as a kind of poetics right where you
have sort of top of the mean bottle the
meme kind of construction so yeah hi how
would you detect sarcastic comments I
mean is it possible to detect sarcasm in
sentimental analysis which is that is
the piece when you give a questionnaire
people you know tend to come up with
some sarcasm how it is pop back um so
first of all it's certainly the case
that sarcasm is is hard
but Vader does a reasonably good job of
it within the sort of societal norms of
Twitter so there are rules with invaders
specification and you can you can read
them all in fact so which is one of the
things that's nice about Vader is it's
very easy to see transparently what
they're using to make determinations and
so they have I think I think Vader is
something on the order of eight or nine
thousand specific rules and a good chunk
of them are for understanding sort of
trickier situations and sentiment
Alice's they aren't going to work if
what you're analyzing is a three
paragraph customer review right they
might they might work on any individual
sentence taken isolation from those
things but because it's working from
this assumption that you are restricted
to 140 characters so you've got maybe
one maybe two sort of short coherent
sentences and that's what it's analyzing
so your sarcasm can't be a whole
sentence that makes in retrospect the
last three sentences sarcastic right
which is something that you can see in
larger pros so it's not gonna help you
there but Vader's approach does work
quite well in understanding tone through
sort of social media indicators it uses
a whole bunch of emoji vocabulary to
understand these things stuff like
Lowell and these kinds of things and
yeah so with the sort of caveat that I
don't know how long it's going to be
correct right language language moves
and so Vader's only been around for
about two years so it's not totally
clear that it will be sort of updated as
usage changes but I think it's quite a
good approach for short form text and
you can definitely modify it so that
it's more helpful for if you have a
couple of paragraphs things like this
which might be a good approach if you
have a lot of sarcasm you're dealing
with because classification can be hard
in that situation yeah
I was thinking about the throughout the
oldest short Commons um don't but that
was thinking maybe angry people write
shorter comments like stuff like yeah
this sucks and yep a long long yeah no
it's totally valid the problem with that
is the stylistic rules that we're using
don't make any sense for a comment
that's a single emoji or or someone
bashing their keyboard so you know what
would happen there is some of what may
be going on actually here if you want to
sort of think about places where this
data might be missing the story is that
because what we're doing is looking four
counts that the linter flags up against
sentiment well if the lint or doesn't
flag any style things up then it's great
text and that great text might be you
are the worst human ever that makes it
six right so so and you know that I mean
that's a sentence that's fine and if we
you know if we if we throw 800,000 ! to
the indolent or we'll get mad but if we
don't then it's still expressing some
negative sentiment but it's doing it in
a way that the lender is not going to
flag up so in an effort to deal with
some of these issues I throughout the
shorter comments because i think the the
linting approach is not going to do a
fair assessment for very short stuff 1
think about the data he has a I don't
read the whole credit I really just part
of it and it's not a random sample I
read the top rated articles and there
perhaps at top-rated comments so perhaps
if you sample following that kind of
rules perhaps wicked we would see a
different reddit so do you think that
also excused your data or yeah I mean
it's so so sampling the way I did
absolutely like ask you so what I'm
doing is it would be but but its cues in
the way that I wanted because what I was
trying to do was to see if you examine
all of the comments what would you
expect right and and so a random sample
is going to be the best way to do that
it's not good and actually the results
if we find the results surprising then
perhaps it's because they're different
than the part of reddit we commonly see
and the part of reddit we commonly see
is the stuff that is notionally popular
that bubbles up through reddits scoring
system so one of the ways that you could
do this is a sort of second piece of
analysis is to basically run everything
I did but to focus on highly scored
items perhaps the sort of top ten from
each subreddit or the most highly scored
across the whole community this sort of
thing because that would look at this
sort of idea right and again the scores
and actually the score separated into
upvotes and down votes are one of the
pieces of metadata that accompanies the
comments in this data so if if one was
to grab all of this data you could
easily sort of look just at the highly
scored items or sort of top and
percentile stuff based on voting this
kind of thing and you can also look and
see specifically at threads because one
of the things that I'm not looking at
here is sort of argumentative behavior
right so i think when when we think
about sort of trolling comments on
social media it's frequently not just
one person yelling into the wind but but
it's sort of dispute right maybe it's
not a dispute that has any substance but
people are sort of yelling back and
forth and and there there are ways that
you could capture that as well you have
parent ids in in each of these comments
so you can easily build the comment tree
and then you could look and only for
instance you could only examine the
comments that were involved in threads
that were I don't know three or five
long or involved multiple participants
or things like this which would get you
into discussions that have some length
right which might also skew the results
in a way that's potentially narratively
interesting
actually I would be very curious if you
would do cert similar analysis but more
specifically tired maybe political
subjects on reddit or any other but i
have a question related to father and is
it also a political applicable to other
line with other languages humble of you
would use the dutch language and just
look at yeah yeah so um certainly the
general idea of Vader is absolutely
language in specific but because it's
rule-based one of the disadvantages of
rule based languages is that if a
language has different norms and
grammatical features and send structures
then you need some different rules and
that's especially true in the language
so you have to make sure that the rules
make sense for whichever language
community you're dealing with some of
them certainly generalize one of the
nice things about emojis is that they
are in many ways their own language but
you do have to sort of make sure that
they're used the same amongst different
speakers there are some efforts to
translate the rules of Vader to other
languages I don't off the top of my head
know what the Dutch support is like but
because it's also the rules for Vader
are on github so it is fully open source
it's under I think an MIT license and so
certainly things like translation of the
rule set so that they're coherent to
other languages and doing sort of
testing another languages is something
that I have been led to believe the
contributors love so if there isn't
Dutch there's room for Dutch and you
know i think in principle there's no
reason why that approach doesn't work in
other languages okay let's thank Ben
again
you